y'a une mascotte qui va arriver sur
scène une mascotte qui concerne la vie
de quelqu'un quelqu'un quelqu'un avec
quelques quelques uns quelques unes
ghosn je cours pour savoir qui est
concerné par cette mascotte
voici un premier indice déjà j'aimerais
qu'on fasse entrer la mascotte également
c'est pas qu'on sait pas et alors tous
les partis première à nice voilà
regarder la première si vous pensez que
l'on n'oublie jamais son premier flirt
est ce que vous pensez qu'on n'oublie
jamais son premier flirt remercie
d'ailleurs josiane balasko d'avoir fait
de magnéto et jacquot des écoles
publiques cebada ces modems la mascotte
et sur scène merci à la mascotte est
venu d'ailleurs merci beaucoup
est ce que quelqu'un pense qu'on a
retrouvé son premier flirt parce qu'on
va pas se mentir c'est ça on a retrouvé
le premier flirt de quelqu'un autour de
cette table
c'est vrai que c'est lui qu'on avait
retrouvé pour moi là c'est un vrai gars
bien c'est un ne voyez bien tout de
suite déjà ça peut pas être l'ex
d'isabelle debout voilà donc ça va
aujourd'hui quoi neymar y aujourd'hui
bah écoute et apparemment il a fait son
chemin et apparemment ce flirt eu à
porter chance ah ouais bien cherché on a
deuxième indice regarde et que notre
coeur a fait boum
lors de votre première boum au est ce
que votre rigueur a fait boum boum lors
de votre première boum plus bas d'hier
il énigmes du père fouras puis je trouve
une question mais surtout pas vous
inquiéter à 16 heures qu'ils sont en
banane du parc mais dedans
d'accord surtout que vous connaissez
bien les missions non mais il est en
bananes les cherry est ce que vous
pensez que c'est vous c'est votre ex et
c'était là au bout des ongles est c'est
une prof d'anglais qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils parlent pas anglais
ah oui est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
votre première heure alors je pense pas
caroline je pense pas je me souviens de
son prénom est plus isabelle je pense
pas bien que quand on remet à socoa
famille avait des boules de montants des
booms d'accord si elle est sûre groom
gelées sirops et aurait fait un petit
gilles a dit non je crois pas jean
michel basset des mains d'hommes dont je
pense pas que ce soit moi savez vous
avez pu franchir moment là je me
souviens maintenant évident il a démarré
moi c'est pas d'âme pas l'aimer non ça
me dit rien
castaldi alors moi non je ne connais pas
ses mains sachez que la personne
s'appelle maxime maxime est seul et donc
un homme oui maxime est ce que quelqu'un
commence à voir de quoi il s'agit les
lakers n'ont même pas de te lever toutes
tellement eu ces horribles que le
premier vous avez pas mal le premier
forte si je vous dis maxime marotte pour
kerry alors on sait qu'il ya maxime ma
note qu'elle y va il est trop chou et
oui ça va être qui on parle aux ben oui
ben vous étiez très bien ce qui bat c
c'est un ami d'enfance
non non
[Applaudissements]
sap est une amie d'enfance annoncée par
david enfants non mais c'est l'humain
dans la banane
je sais pas on dirait j'ai dit que
c'était maxima note j'ai pas dit que
c'était les coupeurs way qu'est ce que
vous en savez les petits mac c'est ce
qui motive à la basse et c'est vrai
c'est vous parler de boom on a fait nos
premières boums ensemble on a beau
parler vous êtes se maquiller d'actifs
et la life quoi c'est sûr du céline dion
ah oui oui oui
ah ouais on était en cinquième il paraît
que c'est une bonne élève a donc au
deuxième à 10 la dernière année d'études
d'abord écouté maxime de venir me
rejoindre d'abord en mascotte
[Applaudissements]
m
la bâtisse à la sauce
on avait la vendée on a tous envie de
voir la tête du premier flirt de qu'est
la musique ont bien savoir et c'est lui
qui chante ainsi faire parce que maxime
il est chanteur il a un album en
préparation maximino maxime déjà je
voulais dire merci d'être là d'un amour
années de rien alors maxime avant qu'on
voit dans découvre son visage que
c'était le premier faire de kelly vous
étiez dans la même classe en sixième
ouais c'est sa vie vous êtes restés dans
le même établissement scolaire jusqu'à
la seconde
oui tout à fait j'aime bien maxime je
trouve sympathique
by louis maxime le premier slow c'est
elle qui vous invite à danser
et ouais ouais je sais comment ça s'est
passé maximum un an on était chez claire
à côté de moi c'est clair c'est notre
première boum aie aie aie bas elle est
venue invite à danser moi j'étais trop
timide away et ça se voit donc la vie
est moins timide maintenant ouais ça va
ça va trois qui ont trahi alors qu'il y
paraît que c'était une bonne élève
ouais et tu nous a ramené des photos
parce que j'ai dit à l'époque ce n est
pas du tout le même style décès mandela
même eu les cheveux rouges en troisième
ibère est ce que vous avez des photos de
kelly vélo vélib l'époque s'il vous
plaît c'est agatha voilà regardé c'était
faux et on retourne à d'autres photos de
kelly c'était vraiment l'ado dans le
groupe mais regardez le teaser
un crédit en dirait benhaim rien à voir
c'est l'été il fait chaud là dedans oui
regardez de kédougou mais c'est vrai ces
photos eh ben c'est kelly c'est mal
[Rires]
c'est moi mais c'est max non
oui ces photos abbas arrivé
ouais c'est mes photos et le couster
j'avais jamais des photos maxime est ce
que vous vous êtes galocher kelly et toi
c'est un oui quoi jamais non jamais gcs
max c'est pas vrai justin smoak juste un
débat animé c'était quand sa troisième
en troisième mais là c'était il n'ya
même pas une petite galoche même pas
comme gilles et il en est mort on nie
pas les faits et la vie alors qu'eddy on
va revoir
maxime puisque vous allez découvrir
maxime avoue maxime merci en tout cas
d'être est en fait on voit toujours
regarder voilà les regards des machines
merci dakar
merci max
jamiroquai est banni
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais que vous repartiez le sio de
ce lourd ah oui tous les deux bah oui
c'est l'heure c'était la vague dance
armés vas-y mon chéri mettez-vous là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes depuis déjà très longtemps
mr bah oui et alors et est ce que vous
pourriez reprendre tous les deux ah ben
moi aujourd'hui chez marine non merde
j'avais vu ça mais castagnos il était
marié à aujourd'hui qui dit moi c'est
comme ma cousine quoi c'est vrai et pour
t&d sûr comme salomon maxime il est trop
miné leurs beaux gosses n'empêche il et
j'aime bien j'aime bien est ce un bon
chanteur et chez trop fier de moi je
suis heureux et fier je suis fière
d'elle de c'était le juge vient elle est
géniale et un album qui va sortir
ouais c'est ça tu verras nous ferons là
ils vous parlent pas mais avec les
garants plaisir est un amour d'abord
[Applaudissements]
oui
lancée
[Applaudissements]